en el vídeo pasado hicimos lo siguiente
empezamos con una cierta curvas y
después le dimos una parametrización x
de 7 a partir de esta parametrización de
encontramos una nueva que lo que hacía
era recorrer exactamente la misma curva
pero al revés
empezaba aquí y terminaba en este punto
conforme t se movía de ave y en
contraste con lo que pasaba antes que
cuando te era igual a estábamos aquí y
entregó al ave estábamos acá entonces lo
que queremos responder en este vídeo es
la siguiente pregunta como la integral
de línea sobre c de f de xy de s como
esa integral de línea se compara con la
otra integral la integral sobre f x y el
mismo campo escalar pero ahora sobre
esta nueva curva que va en la otra
dirección
- entonces importará que aquí estamos
moviéndonos en un sentido y acá en otro
para encontrar la integral de línea de
este campo escalar en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a hablar de campos vectoriales
pero ahorita tenemos un campo escalar
bueno vamos a agarrar un poco de
intuición antes de probar las cosas
hacer un dibujo a ver ahí voy a poner mi
diagrama no sabes que me voy a ir aquí
abajo para tener más espacio y entonces
déjame dibujar lo siguiente voy a
dibujar el eje y por aquí voy a dibujar
el eje x y vamos a poner también el eje
z el eje z
voy a dibujar un campo escalar es decir
voy a dibujar una superficie algo así
y entonces recuerda que este de aquí es
fx y lo estamos pensando así porque a
cualquier punto le podemos asociar una
altura definida justo por el campo
escalar ok entonces vamos a poner una
curva aquí abajo
digamos algo de este estilo esta de aquí
va a ser la curva ce y para darle un
sentido empezamos aquí y nos movemos en
esta dirección va entonces ahorita es un
buen momento para recordar qué quiere
decir la integral de línea
geométricamente lo que queremos según
vídeos anteriores es encontrar el área
de una cortina cuyo techo está definido
por la superficie y cuya base es la
curva entonces literalmente estamos
intentando encontrar el área de esta
pared o cortina o papel o como quieras
llamarle esto es lo que está detrás de
esta expresión pero qué pasa si tomamos
la misma integral pero ahora en la
dirección contraria es decir en vez de
ir en esa dirección ahora vamos al revés
comenzamos arriba y empezamos a bajar
pues fíjate que de cualquier forma la
idea es la misma o sea no sabemos cuál
es
y una forma de pensarlo es que pude
haber definido este camino o sea en esa
dirección como sé y entonces menos se
sería pues el pse original
entonces parece ser que en cualquier
caso estamos determinando el área de
esta cortina entonces que nos dice la
intuición vámonos a las integrales pues
ambas nos dan el área de esta cortina
verdad y por tanto deberían de ser
iguales pero fíjate que todavía no he
demostrado nada rigurosamente vamos a
ver otro argumento intuitivo lo que
tenemos en esta integral de aquí es un
de s verdad déjame subrayar lo aquí
tenemos un de ese y eso en el dibujo es
un diminuto segmento de curva verdad un
diminuto segmento de curva que se
multiplica por la altura por un f x eso
de ahí nos da el área de un cierto
rectángulo y la integral suma todos esos
en la otra pasa lo mismo otra vez
estamos tomando un pequeño de ese y
acuérdate que el de ese siempre es una
raíz cuadrada entonces queda positivo o
sea tomamos un pequeño de ese y otra vez
estamos multiplicando por la misma
altura y una vez más estamos sumando
de todos estos rectángulos hay que tener
cuidado pues este fenómeno no sucede con
las integrales normales digamos la
integral de a a b de pues una f de x vx
en estas integrales cuando
intercambiamos los límites entonces qué
pasa nos queda igual al negativo de la
integral hasta desde el df de x de x
déjame hacer un dibujo para entender
esto a ver aquí está el eje el eje x
aquí está aquí está ve y la gráfica de
la función entonces en esta primera
integral los de x siempre son positivos
es decir aquí tenemos un pequeño cambio
pero es positivo porque pues porque
estamos avanzando empezando en nada y
terminando en ve hacia la derecha pero
en esta situación las de x son negativas
porque ahora qué sucede en las alturas
son las mismas pero ahora la x se mueve
hacia la izquierda desde b hasta y
entonces cada de x es negativo en la
integral de línea no pasa esto en ambos
casos como de s es una raíz nos queda
positiva además como la superficie la
dibuje sobre el plano xy entonces efe
también es positiva
y entonces esto nos debería de sugerir
que no hay ningún cambio de signo pero
ahora sí para quedar contentos
hagamos una demostración voy a bajar
aquí al gran gran espacio y comencemos
escribiendo la parametrización pongamos
que se está dada por x igual a x dt y es
igual a 7 y que además la testa en un
cierto intervalo digamos a menor o igual
a t menor o igual a b sabemos que vamos
a necesitar las derivadas entonces
déjame hacerlas de una vez entonces lo
voy a poner con este otro color de x dt
es igual a x prima de t y deje de t
a ver un poquito más bonito del dt es
igual a mi prima de te va hasta ahorita
nada nuevo simplemente una
parametrización y unas derivadas pasemos
a la integral sabemos que la integral
sobre c de f x
efe es un campo escalar verdad la
integral de fx de s está definida por la
integral desde te iguala hasta b c
efe de x dt coma
y todo eso multiplicado por la raíz
cuadrada de de equis dt cuadrada o sea x
primate cuadrada x prima de t al
cuadrado más de 7 t al cuadrado
entonces nos queda más de prima de t al
cuadrado y claro verdad todo eso por dt
nada nuevo todavía sólo pusimos esta
integral en términos de la
parametrización que tenemos vale
entonces ahora pasemos a la otra a menos
c voy a cambiar a otro color digamos a
naranja entonces menos c está dada por
bueno sabes qué mejor déjame hacerlo
aquí abajito menos se está dada por x
igual a y eso ya lo hicimos en el vídeo
pasado verdad vamos a ver que nos
quedaba nos quedaba x es igual a x de a
más b - t ok x es igual
v - t y luego he estado
espérame aquí me equivoqué verdad o sea
me faltó una x x es igual a x de a más b
- t y luego ya está dado por llegue a
más b - t y finalmente estamos en el
mismo intervalo a menor o igual a b me
perdón a menor o igual a t menor o igual
a b va entonces esto de aquí es
simplemente lo que hicimos en el vídeo
pasado x es igual a x de además b - t y
es igual a yemen usted es la misma curva
pero recorrida en sentido contrario sale
pues ahora vamos a encontrar las
derivadas regresando al color blanco
ahora lo que queremos es de x dt para
esta nueva trayectoria menos suena que
ahora vamos a tener que usar la regla de
la cadena
entonces nos queda la derivada de lo de
adentro con respecto a t estas son
constantes a que hay un menos te la
derivada de menos 3 -1 entonces es menos
1 por la derivada de lo de afuera
lo de adentro entonces nos queda x prima
en b menos te sale vamos a reescribir
esto simplemente como - x prima de amas
ve - te vamos ahora la deje de g
dt de modo similar es igual a la
derivada de lo de adentro o sea menos 1
verdad derivada de menos 3 - 1 x la
derivada de lo de afuera evaluado en lo
de adentro o sea prima de amave menos te
vamos a describirlo como menos prima de
a más b - te sale ahora si ya tenemos
toda la información descrita vamos a
pasar a la integral entonces ahora
queremos encontrar la integral sobre
menos c d
efe de x de s
ok entonces esto va a ser igual a la
integral desde t igualada hasta te
iguala b
efe de equis pero ahora x ya no es x de
verdad ahora x está en esta nueva
trayectoria o sea es x d
b - t no te dejes intimidar por esto vas
a ver que va a quedar más bonito al rato
entonces vamos allá ahora nos queda algo
parecido verdad ahora yes idea más bien
usted entonces ya de ve - t cerramos el
paréntesis y luego hay que multiplicar
por la raíz cuadrada déjame ponerlo en
azul la raíz cuadrada de que pues desde
x dt al cuadrado de x dt al cuadrado y
cuánto vale esto pues es esta expresión
al cuadrado aquí hay un menos verdad
pero cuando elevamos al cuadrado pues se
cancela el menos porque el elevar al
cuadrado siempre cancela menos entonces
nos queda menos x prima de además de
todo eso elevado al cuadrado que es lo
mismo que simplemente x prima de a más
vehemente al cuadrado simplemente al
menos lo cancelamos porque estamos
elevando al cuadrado
entonces x prima de a
v - t al cuadrado ahora toca poner lo
que corresponde para y pongámosle más de
tdt y por la misma lógica perdemos el
menos verdad entonces nos queda
simplemente que prima de amas ve - t
elevado al cuadrado va todo esto hay que
multiplicarlo por un dt sale entonces
esta de arriba es la integral de
superficie sobre la curva c y esta de
acá abajo es la no haber ni siquiera
hemos hablado de integrales de
superficie más bien esta es la integral
de líneas sobre c y éste la integral de
línea sobre menos c todavía no parecen
iguales de hecho la segunda se ve más
complicada veamos si podemos simplificar
la movámonos para acá abajo y vamos a
meter un truco vamos a hacer un cambio
de variable para esto vamos a tomar pues
vamos a ponerle y entonces vamos a tomar
y iguala a más b - t necesitamos
encontrar la derivada y cambiar los
límites de integración empezamos con la
derivada a ver
/ dt pues está fácil verdad simplemente
es igual a menos 1 escrito de otra forma
multiplicando a ambos lados por dt nos
queda que de eeuu es igual a menos
dt ahora pasemos a los límites de
integración a ver entonces cuando te es
igual a a que le pasa a uno pues es
igual a a más ve menos a que es igual a
b y cuando te es igual a b entonces uno
es igual a más b - b verdad y estoy aquí
es igual a a saleh entonces cuando
hacemos la sustitución en esta integral
de aquí vamos a ver qué nos queda seguro
se va a simplificar entonces nos queda
la integral
de ahora empezamos a ver cuando ustedes
y entonces cuando te ve huesa ahora nos
queda
efe de x de aquí tenemos a + bms - t que
simplemente es un
bajo coma y de lo mismo verdad u otra
vez de eeuu
ok y luego hay que multiplicar por la
raíz cuadrada de déjame hacerlo con
color azul por la raíz cuadrada de x
prima de a más de otra vez es un elevado
al cuadrado más de prima de entonces
prima de v al cuadrado
todo eso x pues ahora no es de verdad
ahora va de como más bien nos quedaría
dt es igual a menos de eeuu y entonces
por aquí en vez de poner un dt tenemos
que poner un menos de eeuu por menos de
u pero para no pensar que es una resta
déjame poner el menos aquí afuera vale
entonces nos quedó la integral debe a de
este integrante ok ahora para que los
límites de integración tengan un poquito
más de sentido déjame intercambiarlos o
sea el más chiquito que él ve entonces
lo que dije hace rato es que si tenemos
una integral normal y está como está es
verdad que va de a mejor déjalo ponerle
que va debe a a de fx de equis o déjame
ponerle de un jefe de un déu entonces
eso es igual a menos la integral de ave
de f
y eso lo hicimos aquí arriba lo que
dijimos fue que cuando intercambiamos
los límites de integración entonces los
dedos también cambian de signo sale
entonces hagamos eso aquí abajo a ver
entonces nos queda vamos a intercambiar
estos dos entonces qué nos queda aquí
hay un menos verdad entonces nos va a
quedar menos x menos nos va a quedar
simplemente la integral de ave de el
menos se va porque intercambiar los
límites entonces nos queda la integral
de ave de fx de 1,71 multiplicado por la
raíz por la raíz de x prima de perdón
aquí apareció algo x prima del elevado
al cuadrado
más prima de 1 al cuadrado de 1 listo
terminamos con la sustitución pero esto
de dónde venía vamos a copiar la
integral original vamos a acordarnos que
era igual a la integral sobre menos c de
fx y de ese entonces fíjate que tenemos
cómo se relaciona esto con la integral
de c a ver déjame copiar y pegar la
nuestra no es copiar y pegar a ver voy a
copiar y pegar esto de aquí copiar
bajo
pegar a esta entonces cómo se comparan
estas dos integrales pues si las vemos
con cuidado la verdad se ven súper
parecidas aquí en la integral
correspondiente a menos c tenemos un
montón de uso y acá abajo tenemos un
montón de text pero en exactamente los
mismos lugares
estas dos integrales van a tomar
exactamente el mismo valor cuando acá
abajo hacemos el cambio digamos o igual
a t entonces esta integral queda la
integral de a a b d pues lo mismo de acá
verdad o sea de fx de 1 x de mathieu
por la raíz cuadrada de x prima de un
elevado al cuadrado más ye prima de eeuu
elevado al cuadrado de eeuu y entonces
estas dos ya quedan idénticas ba
entonces hicimos toda la sustitución y
así y obtuvimos las mismas integrales el
resultado es que no importa en qué
dirección tomamos la curva siempre y
cuando tomemos la misma curva eso está
muy bien pues coincide con el argumento
intuitivo que teníamos lo que habíamos
dicho es que en ambos casos estábamos
encontrando el área de esta cortina